Speaker 1: Well, I have an opportunity today
to do two things that I think are valuable.
One is debunk a false talking point that is
spreading like wildfire.
And number two, to remind everybody that the
entire Tulsi Gabbard thing was a complete
and total scam.
Tulsi Gabbard Who?
So I guess somebody I thought was on the left
at one point when she ran for president and
when she was a Democrat, she continues to
provide a reactionary takes on Fox News.
And last night, she provided a reactionary
take that is a great opportunity to explain
reality to her and to people in the audience
and to make sure that we're all equipped with
the truth about this question.
Did the Supreme Court leaker commit a crime?
Because for all the talk about due process
that the right claims to support, they are
increasingly demanding the prosecution and
imprisonment of the Supreme Court leaker absent
any actual crime that we can point to that
they committed.
So let's start with Tulsi.
You might be shocked that Tulsi appeared to
express outrage.
That the decision leaked.
Not that women's autonomy will now be allowed
to be restricted by states.
She was outraged that we learned about this
three weeks early.
Let's take a listen.
Speaker 5: To be heard.
I think it's also critical to point out that
this leak sets a very, very dangerous precedent
for our Supreme Court for three important
reasons.
Number one is, first of all, this person is
a thief who stole this information, released
it with a very specific intent to try to incite
protesters and intimidate and pressure our
Supreme Court justices to make a political
decision rather than a decision that is based
on the Constitution.
Number two, we have the fact that Supreme
Court is not in place to legislate from the
bench people's representatives.
Speaker 1: And yet that's exactly what they're
doing with this decision.
Speaker 5: State level at the federal level
are charged to make laws, not the Supreme
Court.
The Supreme Court needs to make decisions
based on the Constitution.
And the Department of Justice, lastly, needs
to go and prosecute this crime, which is exactly
what it is, and make an example out of the
person who leaked this information.
Because our Supreme Court justices cannot
operate under the fear that they will have
partizan political activists in their house
intimidating and threatening their ability
to do their job per the Constitution.
Speaker 1: Okay, so Tulsi uses the word thief
and that sounds criminal.
I don't know if theft is illegal, right?
But it wasn't that we know of a crime.
So that's one thing I'm going to talk about.
The second piece of this is she insists that
this was someone who didn't like the forthcoming
decision to overturn Roe v Wade, meaning it's
presumably someone on the left who leaked
this in order to try to pressure the justices
to change their minds.
And sometime between now and whenever the
decision comes out, decide to preserve Roe
v Wade.
I'll get to that part in a second.
So let's start with the crime piece.
This is not about your opinion of whether
it was good or bad that this leaked three
weeks early.
I just want to talk about whether it's a crime
if to get to this document.
Someone at the Supreme Court hacked a computer
they weren't supposed to have access to, physically
trespassed somewhere.
That could be a crime.
We have no evidence of any hacking or trespassing
right now.
Secondly, Supreme Court draft decisions are
not classified.
That's another angle where this is this this
must be like a classified document.
It's not.
So there's no crime there either.
If I want to be as charitable as possible
and say, where could there be a crime here
under the loosest interpretation possible,
you could maybe be charged with stealing federal
government property for your own use.
It's extraordinarily unlikely that you would
see that it's not even clear that it would
necessarily fit.
Now, if an investigation starts and authorities
interview anyone, the leaker or whoever, and
you lie to them, okay, that's a crime that
would be making a federal false statement
charge.
But that's an if.
Okay.
So there's no crime that we're aware of here.
So why would anybody be prosecuted and locked
up?
Because that's what people like to see another
reactionaries are calling for.
Now, one other thing.
If the leaker is a lawyer, they could be subject
to an ethics probe.
They could be subject to being disbarred.
These aren't crimes, but they could lose their
law license.
Bottom line firing?
Sure.
Disbarment.
If a lawyer.
Sure.
Crime?
Almost certainly not.
No evidence of that at this point in time.
Second part, they continue to assume these
right wingers that the leaker is a pro-choice
left winger, angry with the forthcoming decision
to overturn Roe v Wade, releasing this draft
in order to try to put public pressure on
the justices planning to vote in favor of
overturning Roe v Wade.
So they will be scared and they'll change
their mind and they will vote to keep Roe
v Wade.
First of all, lifetime appointments, extremely
good security.
I don't even think it passes the sniff test
that it would work if that's what the plan
was to intimidate the justices planning to
vote to overturn.
But I actually have another perspective here,
which is we're we're only speculating we don't
know who the leaker is.
The leaker could just as likely be a right
winger.
Who leaked this.
In order to try to lock in the justices in
sticking with their decision to overturn Roe
v Wade.
In other words, a right winger might say there
might be justices who in this February draft
wanted to vote to overturn Roe v Wade.
But now maybe because it's May.
Now, remember, this person might know what
happened since the draft is written.
Maybe the leaker is a right winger, doesn't
like abortion and says, Wow, I found out that
I don't know.
Gorsuch is thinking about actually voting
to keep Roe v Wade.
I am going to leak this to make their names
public so that they are less likely to change
their vote because that would potentially
cause some kind of uproar or whatever.
The point is, we don't know either way right
now.
At some point we might.
Right now we don't know.
And all of this is completely irresponsible,
particularly saying that people who have not
committed any crime that we're aware of or
that can be articulated should be prosecuted
and put in prison, as so many like Ted Cruz
have been demanding